President Trump and the first lady will
head to Pittsburgh this afternoon to
offer support for a city trying to heal
from the deadly synagogue shooting parts
of the city skyline were bathed in blue
light last night to honor the 11 people
killed David beg no is outside the Tree
of Life synagogue in Pittsburgh David
one of the most painful live shots I've
ever been at I've been thinking about it
all night be on a good morning it's
still just as quiet here this morning as
it was when you and I stood here
yesterday we anticipate the president is
going to come here to the synagogue with
the first lady mr. Trump has already
said he's going to the hospital to visit
one of the wounded officers the man who
police have named as the killer in this
case is not going to get out of jail not
anytime soon that's what a federal judge
told him yesterday
and we were in the courtroom when it
happened Robert Bowers was in a
wheelchair during his roughly 10 minute
court appearance on Monday the 46 year
old accused shooter said very little
except yes when the judge asked him if
he understood the charges against him
which include federal hate crimes that
he could face the death penalty for the
SWAT team found Bauer's in front of the
synagogue as he was trying to get away
I'm coming in from this direction right
here
dr. Keith Murray is medical director for
the Pittsburgh SWAT team he was with
tactical officers as they entered the
building and found five victims in the
main sanctuary he says one of them was
in shock
but still alive she was pulling on to
one of her friends who was deceased and
then we quickly evacuated her so that we
couldn't continue on through the
structure dr. Murray raced upstairs with
his team the gunman was barricaded and
an officer was down he was shot multiple
places so it looks like it took one
round to the head it actually went
through his helmet did his injuries
appear to you in that moment to be life
threat
I mean he was he was gonna die if we
were out there it has been three days
since the violence and emotions in this
tight-knit community are still raw some
including the Pittsburgh Mayor Bill
Peduto fear that a visit from the
president is just too soon the last
thing I want to see is while these
families are burying those that they
lost that there are protests and streets
being closed
and other things that are taking away
from the most important thing that we
can do which is honoring the dead
look the rabbi of the synagogue here the
tree of life says the president is
always welcome but the rabbi of one
left-leaning Jewish group says he wants
the President to stay away until mr.
Trump denounces white nationalism Gail
today the funerals begin among the first
to be buried dr. Gerry Rabinowitz and
David and Cecil Rosenthal they were
brothers it really is time to honor the
victims thank you very much David